[Music]
what's up today in destroying this
destination loose this was submitted by
all dogs must be pit that is weird
more people being able to travel has had
several negative effects on popular
cities oh they're getting trashed by
Torres yeah many tourists we got to
raise the prices month no are doing
there they're fining tourists for
different reasons like they trying to
deter tourism from certain places
because it's just it's too much resort
fees you had resort fees to [ __ ] in
Oklahoma oh my god like sorry thought
these in Vegas are the [ __ ] words
like why do I have to pay absorb fee at
the hotel this will on the strip
I'm not going ATVing I'm not gonna hang
glider where's this resort fee going
right to city tax they just say that
nothing resort fee because I'm a [ __ ]
resort this is a whole ti my man I agree
yeah this article here is just talking
about how recently this phenomenon now
it's known as over tourism and I believe
the Chinese but go on
I blame the Chinese for the home prices
right now oh yeah la it's happening in
Australia too in Hawaii you know buying
up so much [ __ ] Lane as I said the
races to say they are but Chinese or
buying up a lot of land and Hawaii is so
[ __ ] expensive they're they're
funneling money out of China to get
ready to run away from China so all the
top people there the politicians and the
rich people they're just trying to buy
up stuff in if you spend more than I
think a hundred thousand or a million
dollars in the US
you get upgraded to your citizenship oh
really yeah yeah because they only limit
how many people can come here from China
right like every year your each country
gets like a limit oh it's like if only
100 people can come from China they have
up so up the line bump yeah to get this
fast pass I feel like this is some
insider information how the [ __ ] do you
know this right now I guess cuz Asians
we went to the Asian predominant like
neighborhood uh-huh
so like we were looking for houses like
the past two years
mm-hm this phenomena is been going on
for like the past ten years yeah and
there'd be houses that we see that we
kind of like and we just go on Zillow
whatever and we would send it to our
agent and a lot there's just so many
empty homes in this entire area they're
just but just put the money there and
you can only live in it and then when
you look at the actual like registered
like ownership papers it's registered by
a Chinese corporation I'm squatting a
bit white midnight house and I'm gonna
put my photo chained and everything yeah
I just people would never yet nobody
ever seen I always lead to the back door
me and my wife just buy a house and we
we've learned about this ship to that
and also my wife's dad has a neighbor
who he's never seen how she's been there
for [ __ ] years how about Chinese
corporation the grass always gets cut
everything you know but there's never a
car showing up never a Carly yeah that's
so creepy was a cool at the same time
like I would love to do that and I [ __ ]
out some neighbors and [ __ ] yeah like
you wouldn't even see somebody decorate
the house do it like literally at 3
o'clock 3:00 a.m. to 4:00 a.m. doing it
and nobody sees it they just come out as
like Halloween's their grade oil spill
the driveway just gets wider and wider
wait I have never seen a car here didn't
see this is rich people pranks we got to
do it oh my god not gonna Davis door
give a basket first movie but like
nobody knows this all started cause it
Chinese tours that all started their day
just they do mention that China is
responsible for much of the over tourism
because for example they're saying here
that overseas trips made by Chinese
citizens it was at ten point five
million in the year 2000 now it's
estimated about a hundred and fifty six
million last year no Chinese travel
enroll like if you never tried to go to
Hawaii you're not getting the
first-class seat I'll give a [ __ ] how
many miles and points you have they buy
out the whole first class you got
sitting there Brad you better go for it
oh no listen 100 bucks your kids no kids
on the Tyrian don't take them too wide
and I gotta remember that [ __ ] okay you
can tell them this [ __ ] I've been
trained
every [ __ ] job the kid to Japan by
choice I want to let them with Grandma
but when he was a baby I could point at
the I have alphabet on his one article
ABCD and then a couple months later he
started pointing and seeing it to me the
same way mimicking that's not like
remember Lanza will never [ __ ] babies
like fresh babies they don't even see
correctly you're just a moment yeah you
weren't I agree yes so I'm like they're
not gonna remember that [ __ ] for it
they're not gonna remember how much
money you spent how about a one-year-old
in Japan what do you think that oh just
sounds disgusting around this [ __ ]
lop a baby on your own walks he walks I
thought you said it was one yeah he's
mine
well then he's not walking his bucket
Waterloo no he's running he's Dorner
drunk whoo he's badass yeah I don't
follow I was like [ __ ] I pick a blob
there yeah but you see they got to
experience a city with their
one-year-old son
you brought a [ __ ] cockatoo with you
and then see how the [ __ ] that you like
Japan I thought by choice not by talk
yes the most white person [ __ ] ever like
I just stopped not sleeping with an
animal that we eat his own pool my wife
do that by what happen
don't do that that sex is don't do that
no cuz I even would've did that so what
do you guys I would've stopped that [ __ ]
a lot of sexism I would I will say is
they have very big kennels you could get
her a bit Kindle and she could sleep
with the cat in the kit trained into
their [ __ ] minds man I only got with
them I think six years after she already
hadn't so I have no shot it's single
parents or pet owners that are worse to
jump in a relationship with cuz that
[ __ ] kid or that [ __ ] bad is it it
already has so much stake in a
relationship
the cat doesn't like you my I don't know
why furry doesn't like you we got to
figure this out no we know it's a
[ __ ] cat and when you go to work I'm
gonna the back door over there we might
have to web this conversation you care
if I'm alive honestly I think you give a
[ __ ] if I'm if I'm in here but they
follow her wherever she goes so I'm like
through your castle cats and we have a
dog and I remember when we got the dog
it was the date of Paul Walker passed
away in this accident so my garbage
elves like y'all working this hard you
could just lose it all tomorrow sounds
like y'all get the dog right get the dog
and the first night first couple nights
I mean he's like three weeks old so at
that small they gotta get the training
pass so every night he pees all this
training pad about 2:30 morning and any
types until this might clears it like
that
he doesn't she so vote for these helpers
asleep they don't hear so I had to get
up and change the training path with his
[ __ ] dog that I don't like and it's
always been like that they always ask me
you buy it because I didn't buy it
I let her buy it I gave her the money to
buy I didn't buy anything so like my
daughter is supposed to walk him and
feed him and give him water in the
morning a lot of times she will leave
and forget to feed him water and then
I'm at the house making videos or
something he's looking at me pushing his
ball really I don't [ __ ] with you okay
your master decided she needed to go
learn arithmetic and that feeding you
wasn't important you need to give her
this look when she comes home cuz I'm
not doing it so I'm not I'm not either
you're smart no cuz that's how you
become the the parent who has the
[ __ ] dog that's your dog man hey it's
not my dependent I don't claim him I'm
gonna get eat early and come credit for
claiming this [ __ ] dog okay I only
want this [ __ ] dog I said we should
get rid of him because we violate my
lease as well as he is right we
shouldn't have this even though he's a
little small [ __ ] and he always comes up
to me like he wants my luck you always
want what you can't have and you gave
her those you care enough buddy to
actually go get it man I did cuz I tried
you know I'm a softie on the inside
but when I put my foot up on my [ __ ]
foot died like he walked off [ __ ] now
I'm not walking his dog I open the
sliding door
go ahead you'll [ __ ] I'll leave mother I
saw your Instagram you have a bunch of
pictures with you walking the dog
outside no I did not know there that
would never be what's going on here with
the whole tourism [ __ ] well sick lay the
site it's right [ __ ] these dogs these
kids though
and he's tourists yeah well they're just
saying like you know for example the
Louvre it's suffocating with tourists it
was pretty bad been like that though the
Louvre been like that no but like it's
just getting worse because now there's
cheaper flights Airbnb is making stay
cheaper than hotel we had the thing at
the Louvre to that you can't win it
things why don't they just double the
prices at the Louvre make you like a
hundred water's a particular side there
won't be a horrible for locals
maybe locals can have like a local score
that is inflating like just living in
the city for the local people so for
example there those 30 million visitors
a year to Barcelona where the population
is just 1.6 million 20 million visitors
to Venice where the populations 50,000
oh damn like you know don't be so
enticing then local born city had enough
that's crazy just causing traffic jams
and we're making everything always like
that dude can they just split the
[ __ ] studios up already like move a
studio to Florida or something just so
all the actors don't move to one city
that's true they do they have they have
they have so do they shoot in Atlanta
they get a lot of discounts in Detroit
you already film New York Chicago they
also do a lot of filming in Vancouver
you ought to be like LA sisters you're
not doing [ __ ] auditions over there
what I feel I feel like if you know if
you haven't had a lot of look and you
haven't blown yet you should move to one
of the smaller like settings until you
can move to LA LA like the big this is a
big dog that is like you ain't toured 11
there
reoccurrence I'm like that that's the
problem did the industries here though
so it's like all here we live in a
popular they do it as a formality
I'm telling you what about what about
Chinese home buyers [ __ ] consumer yeah
Barcelona of the rents for the locals
has gone up four percent [ __ ] Barcelona
ven like they are literally the local
people there having protests against
tourists really they hate towards them
and you guys that pain I feel like
that's all locals and tourists towns no
no I don't know any locals that like
tourists Holly live debunking hide
debunking Bali no Bali loves tourism
dude I love your money the only thought
twice it's their whole economy so they
want you to come back and do review
business they [ __ ] are treat you like
saying strippers love their customers I
knew one that loved me she bought masks
were celebs Armani [ __ ] she loved me
man I'm [ __ ] dead dude trust me if
you couldn't I'll show you some of the
textures at me okay [ __ ] that there's
really honestly some feelings
that's what sit min as we find out this
she is a he like it makes sense Steve
guys like the same I know it's not about
that I have a from
that exactly really I know my uncle says
that all the time the strip was like oh
yeah he best ones my real one this one's
the real guys in cars he's won all by
not not expensive course but I still the
car [ __ ] yeah I agree
all right he leases him but he's not
that ball
[Music]
you
you